it's that time of year to check and
upgrade your air conditioner bumble
breeze plumbing and heating and air the
sponsors of this next segment has you
covered with their energy efficient
systems
[Music]
hi guys my name is scott sales manager
with bumble breeze we're in a beautiful
southwest neighborhood home here in las
vegas where a homeowner has decided to
upgrade to some more energy efficient
systems some of the benefits of
upgrading to an energy efficient system
is a quieter operating air conditioner
and your air conditioner can actually
adjust to indoor outdoor temperatures so
you never waste a cent of energy when
you don't need to some of the other
benefits of switching are getting rid of
your old r22 refrigerant which has been
phased out so homeowners can expect
energy savings of anywhere from 50 to 65
percent on upgrading to a variable speed
air conditioner so the system i am
showcasing today are our train
side discharge system the homeowner has
actually went with this type of system
to streamline the look of their home and
not have such a bulky air conditioner on
the side these are also variable speed
air conditioners which can operate at a
level of 43 decibels which you probably
can't hear but i do have one in the
background operating right now
for customers wondering what a variable
speed air conditioner is it is an air
conditioner that adjusts to outdoor and
indoor temperatures so the customer
never wastes energy when they don't need
to your air conditioner will do the best
to not turn on or off it'll actually
speed up and slow down to the heat load
in the house
they're extremely quiet and extremely
energy efficient and because they're
always running in precise parameters
that the engineers designed them to
they're the most reliable air
conditioners on the market also
so variable speed air conditioners are
so important in las vegas because we
size the air conditioner to worst
possible case scenario even though we
only reach those temperatures for a few
weeks out of a few months of the years
we have to prepare so when you do that
your air conditioner is oversized
wasting your money variable speed air
conditioners because they speed up and
slow down to the needs of the home so
head to our website guys and check out
some great offers we have right now
before summer is up we are actually
buying back old air conditioners and you
can receive up to twenty four hundred
dollars for your old out-of-date air
conditioner
thank you to bumble breeze plumbing
heating and air for sponsoring this
segment call
for 702-551-1614 information or visit
bumblebreez.com they're currently
offering up to 2 400 off new energy
efficient systems